- Hello everyone.
I am Priya Natarajan,
the current director of The Franke Program
in Science and the Humanities at Yale,
which is the flagship
interdisciplinary program.
I'd like to welcome you
all to the final talk
in our, Understanding the
Nature of Inference Series
that we've been hosting
at The Franke Program,
exploring inferential models, reasoning,
and experiments across disciplines.
We've had a really rich series of talks,
exciting talks that have
addressed issues relating to
direct causation and correlation,
and how multiple modes of
inquiry help us make sense
of the world and make inferences from it.
So, I invite you all to today's talk
with the intriguing title,
"Inference in a Non-Conceptual World,"
by the wonderful speaker today,
Professor Brian Cantwell Smith.
But before I introduce
our distinguished speaker
for this evening,
I would like to first
recognize our benefactors,
Mr. And Mrs. Richard and Barbara Franke,
whose generosity in funding
interdisciplinary activities
at Yale, has made all our radical
academic silo busting activities
at The Franke Program possible.
I would also like to thank
the John Templeton Foundation
for funding this program of activities,
including this colloquium
and discussion series.
Their support has permitted
us to explore in this series
a novel format, a colloquium
by a distinguished speaker,
followed by deep engagement
with an additional leading
thinker after the colloquium
on a separate day.
In this case, tomorrow
afternoon at the same time.
This unique format has
enabled serious engagement
while giving us some time to
reflect and digest new concepts
that we learned from
the Colloquium speaker,
while also exposing us to
highly relevant alternate
intellectual points of
view from the discussion
the following day.
I am also required to
kindly remind those assemble
that we are recording this event.
And that all participants
videos and microphones
will remain muted.
If you wish,
you can submit questions
through the Q&A feature.
Onto today's speaker,
Professor Brian Cantwell Smith.
Brian Cantwell Smith is
the Reid Hoffman Professor
of artificial intelligence and the human,
as well as being Professor
of information philosophy,
cognitive science,
and the history and philosophy
of science and technology.
And a senior fellow at Massey College
at the University of Toronto.
He actually spoke to us in person
about artificial intelligence,
the challenges, the wins,
and the challenges at our program
just before the onset of the pandemic.
So, we are absolutely
delighted to invite him again.
He received his degrees,
all his degrees, in fact,
from my favorite undergraduate
institution, MIT.
So, here I have to
express my loyalty to MIT.
And from '81 to '96,
he was a principal scientist at Xerox Park
and an adjunct professor
of philosophy at Stanford.
He was the founder of the
Center for the Study of Language
and Information at Stanford University.
Was really ahead of the
game in understanding that
information was going to
start playing an incredibly
important role in society, culture,
creation of new knowledge,
and really the frontier
of technology as well.
He was a founder and first president
of the Computer Professionals
for Social Responsibility
and President for the Society
of Philosophy and Psychology.
And from 1996 to 2001,
he was the professor of cognitive science,
computer science and philosophy
at Indiana University.
And from 2001 to 2003,
he was the Kimberly Jenkins
University distinguished
professor of philosophy and
new technologies and professor
and in the departments of Philosophy
and Computer Science at Duke University.
So, you get the sense
that Ryan has had his foot
in multiple camps,
so multiple feet in multiple camps
throughout his academic career.
So, if there is someone
whose intellectual interests
cannot be siloed, it is him.
He's exemplar of the
interdisciplinary scholarship
that we stand for.
And, Professor Smith moved
to the University of Toronto
in 2003 initially, to serve
as the Dean of the Faculty
of Information and has stayed there since.
And our distinguished
conversant tomorrow afternoon
is Professor Joseph Rouse
from Wesleyan University.
And his primary research
interests are in the philosophy of
science, the history of
20th century philosophy,
interdisciplinary science studies,
and the Social Theory of Practices.
I'll give a much more
detailed introduction to him
before our session tomorrow.
Without further ado,
I turning the floor over to
Professor Brian Cantwell Smith.
Welcome, Brian.
It's all yours.
- Well, thank you very much, Priya,
and thanks to you and to Ty and to Guy
and to the Frankes and to the
Templeton Foundation and so on
and so forth of all the people
for making this possible.
And then also,
thank you all of those who are attending
for a chance to have this conversation.
Cause I really hope it will be a kind of
open-ended conversation.
What I want to convince you of,
if I have a chance is of an orientation,
but not of an answer to a whole.
And I think the orientation
opens up all kinds of questions
to which, as far as I know,
none of us yet have answers.
So, that's what I hope to talk about.
There are four parts to this,
or actually five in a way.
I'm gonna talk about
conceptual representation first
and then the conceptual world, second.
And then non-conceptual
representation, third.
And the non-conceptual world, fourth.
And then on apple log on explainability.
I wanna make one remark before we start
about AI and contemporary AI.
I won't be talking all that much about AI,
but some towards the end.
But, one thing that's true
is I've been in and around AI
for a long time.
In fact, I'm pretty ancient.
I wrote my first big AI program in 1968,
and there have been a lot
of changes since then.
Needless to say,
there was the first wave enthusiasm
and then long periods of AI winter
and a lot of different weather in there.
And a resurgence of
second wave AI and stuff.
What's interesting to me
and sobering is that today,
so for example, when I teach classes,
I'm just finishing one up this fall.
The word AI, the Moniker.AI,
but also the word artificial intelligence,
means statistical generalizations
over massive amounts of data.
That's what the students
just think this is.
A particular kind of data too,
corpuscular non-narrative data,
the sort of data that
can go into databases
or else decontextualize text strings.
And as I've argued in a recent book,
there's no real serious
attempt to get these systems
to understand what they're talking about.
And I think,
there's sort of pure,
there's a wonderful phrase of
Timnit Gebru and others
called stochastical parrots.
That's how they characterize these system,
as stochastical parrots.
And I think there's a
lot of truth to that.
I don't think there's
any real semantics to
these today's systems.
And some people think
that with enough syntax
you get semantics,
which I think is about as
wrong as thinking that if you
travel fast enough in strange
loops on two dimensions,
you're gonna end up in a third dimension.
So, I think AI at the moment
is in a very particular
and rather narrow conception.
That's not how it started.
When I was in MIT in the seventies,
you know, a lot of people
were inspired by the golem,
the myth from Jewish mystical history
in a way that the idea
was that man was created
in God's image, was a recursive plane.
Because if man was in
creating God's image,
then that meant man could
create in God's image
as well and stuff.
A lot of the early pioneers of AI at MIT,
like Marvin Minsky, one of
the founders of the field,
Gerald Sussman, Joel Moses,
who went on to be president
of the university,
admitted not necessarily publicly
that they'd been inspired
by the golem myth as children.
And the idea was that we would
understand understanding.
We would understand the human condition.
We would understand our place
in the universe and how--
Where we came from and so on and so forth.
Marvin Minsky proposed we buy a church
and put a computer on the altar.
Now, that was a little imperialist,
but there was, I think,
a grandeur to that original vision.
Which I think has been lost.
And I think,
I think the aim of this
talk is not to indict
current models of AI
But, when I talk about AI,
you should know that I
come from that tradition,
and I'm not referring to
the current narrow view.
I'm actually referring to
things that might allow us
to move from the current narrow view
to a much bigger, broader,
maybe more inspiring vision.
Okay.
Anyway, part one,
conceptual representation.
So, when philosophers
particularly talk about
the content of a representation,
they refer to something like what it means
or how it presents the world as being.
So, the content might be that
thanks for driving up in
front of the Supreme Court,
or god knows what it is.
We could spend a semester
on the relationship between
what something means and how
it presents the world as being.
But I don't need to,
I don't need to do into that.
I just think for the moment,
a sort of informal notion
of meaning will do.
In 1982, Gareth Evans,
a philosopher at Oxford,
introduced the notion of
non-conceptual content.
Now, non-conceptual content,
if anything is obvious,
it's defined in opposition to the notion
of conceptual content.
And so the question was what intent,
conceptual content was.
And that kind of triggered a whole debate.
Basically, I'm gonna talk about it more,
but conceptual content was
the kind of content that
everybody assumed up until then.
And underlies every form
of logic that you have ever
imagined, including fuzzy logic.
I mean, it's just the sort of model,
on which all these
formal systems are based.
Okay.
What is it in particular?
Conceptual content.
Very roughly, a conceptual representation
is a representation that
represents the world in terms of
objects, properties, relations, sets,
attributes, and so on and so forth.
As in logic, as in model
theory, as in classical AI,
GOFI, as John Hogan called it.
As in XML and so on and so forth.
It's just an extraordinarily
widespread view
about how the world is and
what it is to represent it.
What else, in fact, could it be?
So, we'll get to that in a minute.
But, I wanna say something
about how conceptual content
has been theorized.
Two philosophers in particular
have written in deep ways
about the notion of conceptual content,
people of enormous intelligence.
Gareth Evans, who I mentioned,
who introduced the notion
of non-conceptual content.
He was an enfant-terrible at Oxford.
He died at 34, I think
having done a huge amount of work.
His idea of conceptual
content was a representation
that's algebraically structured.
So, I'm just gonna share the
screen here for a second.
He articulated what he called
a generality condition.
Basically, a representation is
conceptual if it says A is F,
you know, that somebody is tall or
you know...
The storm is gonna be intense
or something like that.
It's conceptual only if the
system that's representing that
is capable of entertaining
the thought or representing
or whatever.
Not only that A is F, but also that B is F
and C is F and so on and so forth
for any other B and c of
which it has a conception.
And also, that A is G and A
is H and so on for any A, G,
and H of when it has Conception.
Modulo various appropriateness conditions.
So, you know,
beans or green might be
okay, dreams are green.
Famous sentence of Chowski's.
Doesn't quite fit because
dreams don't have color.
So, that's an appropriate condition.
But the logical structure takes that form.
Note that this generality
condition is not framed
in terms of syntax,
but it lends itself to
being read syntactically,
which is to say,
if a representation has the
form of A is F or F of A,
syntactically, then that system
is capable of writing down
G of A, or H of A, or H of B, or whatever.
Since contemporary AI reads
everything, syntactically,
in fact it's defined all kinds of words,
including semantics to be words of syntax.
That's a discussion point.
This conception of
conceptuality is very...
Fits swimmingly with
current conceptions of AI
and so on and so forth.
So, a lot of people in
AI just think that this,
that Evan's generality condition
applies to their structures directly.
John McDowell,
perhaps one of the most
important philosophers
in the last 50 years,
has a different there
tradition of being conceptual.
He says that it
representation is conceptual.
If it transparency represents
the world as it is,
ie, it fits into a
judgment about the world.
Not a complete judgment about the world
because there's no such
judgment that would be too big,
but a judgment about a complete world
in the sense of world that's at whole.
On the face of it,
McDowell's characterization
is much less syntactic.
It doesn't have to do with the structure
of the representation itself.
And also, to be honest,
I don't think McDowell's
characterization is anything that
anyone in AI or that any system
in AI is capable of meeting
because it has to be about the world.
But, they're not exactly the same.
So, let's turn to part three,
sorry, part two,
about the conceptual world.
Why are these two
characterizations of conceptual
thought to be sort of the same or at least
comparable or at least compatible?
The reason they're viewed as the same,
I think by most people,
and in fact a lot of
people don't distinguish
between these two characterizations.
I think the reason they're
thought to be compatible
is because of an ontological assumption
that underlies people's
understandings of them.
And a chronological
assumption being an assumption
about the structure of the world,
not the structure of
representation or thought,
but the structure of the world itself.
And that basically,
representations that are structured
according to this generality
condition of Evans represent
the world as it really is.
So, I'm gonna extend ordinary
usage and use the word
conceptual, not just for representations,
but for the world thereby represented.
And I will say that a conceptual
world is the familiar world
in a way to our imaginations
of objects, properties,
relations sets and stuff that
the world itself consists of.
Objects, exemplifying properties,
standing in relations,
grouped together in sets,
exemplifying properties with attributes
and so on and so forth.
So...
So, setting Evans and
McDowell's definitions aside,
I'm gonna actually take
conceptual in my usage,
as any content that has
this ontological character.
Any content that represents
the world in terms of
object properties, relations,
and so on and so forth.
Now...
This assumption that that's
what the world likes,
that's what the world is like,
is extraordinarily widespread.
And it's so widespread
that in fact it's difficult
with students to actually motivate them
or enable them or something,
lead them to believe that anything else
might even be possible.
I wanna point to a wonderful
paper of Jeffrey Nunberg,
who in fact passed away just recently,
on the rise of information.
Jeffrey's an extremely smart guy.
He's such a smart guy that it's
actually sometimes difficult
to figure out that his papers
are as profound as they are.
But he wrote a paper called,
"Farewell to the Information Age",
which, but if we don't get to
the farewell as first of all,
he starts about actually when
did the information arise?
He's tracing the notion of information.
When did it actually
enter our conceptions?
Priya pointed out that
information is a hugely
important notion.
Now, underlies all kinds
of technical projects,
scientific projects.
But, he wants to know sort of
when was it invented, as it were?
And he goes back to the--
Through history, to the
rise of print, basically,
when print became in fact
common form of public discourse.
And, his sense is that
print led to the idea
of snippets of text being
extractable and recombinable
in ways that actually could then convey
content about the world.
Like the temperature is 96 degrees or,
you know, pine trees are
green or whatever it might be.
And his characterization of
information is that it was the
idea that the nature of the
world is such that it can be
reduced to these corpuscular
compact little bits
of quote on quote, information, right?
In fact, Jeff's such a colorful guy.
I once asked him,
I dunno if this is in print or not,
but it's what in fact information was.
And he said, "Oh, information?
That's what happens when you
take a book and you shake it
by the spine so hard that
all the words fall out."
And I think that's a good way to remember
his sense that it's,
it's the sort of erosion
of any sense that narrative
is the locus of our understanding.
And instead that our
claims about the world
are in fact, come in these little bits.
There are other assumptions
underlying this notion of
information too,
that the properties are
concepts and stuff that
these bits of the world
exemplify our uniform
across all instances.
So all pine trees,
not that they're all the same,
but in being a pine tree,
they're pinetreeness is
uniform across all pine trees.
And so on and so forth.
So that you could in fact have pine tree
as the type of a plant in a
database or something like that.
- Brian, I have a quick question.
- Yes.
- But this kind of getting to the essence
of the pinetreeness,
- Right.
- Sort of the essential portfolio,
does it always imply a
reduction, reductionism?
- Well, it--
Boy, I wish I had a bottle of whiskey
and I could pour virtual
glasses of whiskey around.
It doesn't imply reductionism.
I mean, first of all,
reductionism is not itself technically
particularly well defined.
One version of reductionism
is that there's a basic
foundational set of
fundamental primitives.
Like, physical primitives
or something like that.
And that you can build
everything up outta them.
This assumption--
I don't necessarily
have a good name for it,
but it's not that, you
might have, you know,
midwife in a database or you know...
User friendly as a
characterization of a system.
And you'd still think
that user friendly is a
sort of formal concept in
the sense that it can be
applied to something, without
actually thinking you can
reduce any of the concept to any others.
So, you could have gazillion,
you could have every word
in the dictionary in there.
So, it's not actually
reductionist in the classic sense.
It does have a bit of character
of reduction of everything
to these corpuscular bits.
But, not to an underlying level
out of which they're assembled.
So, that's just an important distinction.
- Thank you.
Yeah, for that clarification.
- Okay, so let's turn to
non-conceptual representation.
As I say, it was introduced
by Garreth Evans in 1982.
He's an enfant-terrible of Oxford.
I actually knew him at
MIT as a graduate student
by coincidence and by my luck.
And he strode,
I would meet him at two in the morning,
I mean, not by plan,
I would just run into him at
two in the morning in Cambridge
and he would be striding around.
And he thought Cambridge, Mass.
was not a big enough place
to do philosophy because
there wasn't not enough place
for long walks in the middle of the night.
But anyway,
he introduced the notion of
non-conceptual representation.
Now, because it was Evans,
when he said non-conceptual
representation,
he was obviously character
rising it as non-conceptual with
respect to his own
definition of conceptuality.
So it was the algebraic, you know,
some kind of algebraic
combination of parts,
A is F, B is H, and so on and so forth.
Not to McDowell's.
Is introduction of the notion
of non-conceptual content
led to quite a debate about
what non-conceptual is,
non-conceptual content is.
The fact that it's negatively
defined doesn't help.
There's a question of whether
you could have non-conceptual
judgments in thought,
or only in perception.
You could have a question
of whether they just occurred in action.
There was a question of whether
creatures that don't have
conceptual powers,
like simple animals and
stuff can actually exhib--
Can actually have a
non-conceptual judgment
and so on and so forth.
What are some examples though,
to give you a feel?
Evan's had this example
of being in this study
late at night.
And they're being a s--
Thinking he's completely alone
and there's a step on the floor,
unmistakable step on the
floor right behind him,
and he freezes in terror.
Now, he knows exactly where
that footstep happened, right?
It's just his imagination is riveted.
But, he doesn't have conceptual resources
with which to describe that space.
It's not like 137.6 degrees to my right
and 2.1 meters behind me
or something like that.
It just wasn't--
It wasn't given to him in conceptual form.
And yet it was,
it had content and it was very precise.
Similarly, if I'm teaching tennis,
which God knows you don't
want to have happen,
but anyway,
suppose I tell someone to
hit their second serve,
suppose their second serve
is going out and I say,
look, you're hitting it too hard.
Just hit it at the speed
at which paper is ejected
from the big copier at the office,
I mean your department or something.
It's not clear.
I mean,
that's a speed and you know
that the paper is coming outta
the copier at a certain speed,
but, you don't know what
speed that is in any way that,
you know, like miles an hour.
And even if it did,
it's not clear you would
be able to hit a serve
at that many miles an hour.
It's that form of understanding
of speed that you have both
for papers ejected from
copiers and for tennis serve.
They're not,
they're not conceptually formulated.
Adrian Cousins a foster
who was a postdoc of mine
way back when in the eighties, I guess.
He got a PhD in Oxford and he was stopped.
He rode a motorcycle late at night.
So, maybe the late at night
is a theme of this talk.
He was stopped by the police
and they hauled him up
and said, "Look,
do you know how fast you were going?
And Adrian said, "Well, in one way I know,
and in one way I don't know",
which I don't think was a
good thing to say to police.
But what he meant was he
knew how fast he was going
around the corner.
It was wet and it was sandy,
and he knew that he
could go only that fast
before skidding out.
He could probably do it again
and without a very small
margin of error, repeat the same velocity.
But it was not given to him conceptually,
he didn't know how many
kilometers per hour he was going
and whether he was over the speed limit.
And probably he knew he
was over the speed limit.
But, the point is his
sense of that speed was not
conceptually articulated
and so on and so forth.
Evans argued that a great
deal of our knowledge,
especially perceptual knowledge,
is in this non-conceptual form.
Now, that notion of
non-conceptual content of Evans
did drive a bit of a wedge
through Evans and McDowell.
A wedge not well understood.
For example,
so as you go to a furniture store,
and you are with your partner
and you say to them,
"Look, hey, shall we buy those curtains?"
And your partner says, "No, look.
That red won't go with our sofa."
Now, what does that red refer to?
It refers to a shade of red.
There are different shades of red.
You know, some might be,
might come out blood in occult ceremonies
and burgundy wine.
Another might come out lipstick and
orlon sweaters, and muffy
at a prep school dance.
For Evans, those are different judgments.
And the differences matter
as regard conceptuality
cause they differ.
Those differences matter
with respect to conceptuality
because how it is that those differences
manifest in your mind is not
conceptually explicable to you.
So, that judgment, that red,
is whatever, not the right one,
is not a conceptual
judgment on Evan's part.
For McDowell, it's a
different judgment too.
But with respect to
defensive conceptuality,
he doesn't care because
that's a judgment about
the nature of the world.
Which is given to you in your
understanding of the world.
So, he thinks that's a
fine conceptual judgment.
So, crack started to appear
in this whole debate.
Which I'm not gonna go into.
I wanna push though, on the
notion of non-conceptual content
because if we go deeper,
I think we start to open
stuff up in ways that touch
contemporary AI and possibilities
for inference and stuff.
Okay, so part four, the
non-conceptual world.
I, myself have never
believed that the world
of full was conceptual.
It may have stemmed from my misspent youth
being...
Taking place in the Canadian north.
So...
So, I used to go paddling
around in Whitewater rivers.
And I just don't think
there are objects out there.
I mean, of course there's
some objects, there's rocks.
But, if we're talking about
re-identifiable particulars
under a category, you know,
what category rock exactly
is this and how many rocks
are there there?
The thing underneath
the water on the right,
is that one or is it 17?
Or is that bedrock?
If you're gonna characterize rocks,
there's no sort of natural
boundary between the rocks
and pebbles and sand,
and god knows what all.
One of the things that
you have to do in paddling
whitewater is you've got to go into the,
into the arrow of a V of dark
water pointing away from you.
And your life is often at
stake if you do this wrong.
But, how many Vs are
there in this picture?
I don't know.
If you're paddling through
this maelstrom of spray
and waves and rocks and clouds
and all this kind of stuff,
there's no way to individuate.
I mean, you may have enormous skill,
but there's no way to
individuate what's going on
in ways that conceptual
representations require.
I think the way conceptual
representations work is different
from how they are classically conceived.
And Priya, this actually gets
a little bit at your idea
about whether this whole view
of conceptual representation
is reductive.
My sense is that conceptual
content informs a form of
abstraction over a
fundamentally profuse richness
in the underlying world.
That is essentially a
conceptual achievement
to box and construct categories
and so on and so forth.
In order to bring things
out there under a regiment
of intelligibility.
And that's sort of the norm
on conceptual representation
is to render the world
intelligible by abstraction.
Now, how does this work?
If you'll forgive me,
I'm gonna actually put up
another slide.
Now, in this figure.
This is a waterfall plot
for people who know about
such things.
It doesn't matter.
Suppose this...
Suppose this was a sort
of topographic set of
vertical slices through a landscape
at the edge of a lake
or something like this.
And then suppose somebody says,
"Look, we should go up
one of the two ridges
towards the left end of this picture."
What are they referring
to by the two ridges?
You know, one possibility is
that those are the two ridges
they're referring to.
Another possibility is
that they're the left two
are the ones that they're referring to,
and they think the one on the right
is different from what it was
that the person on the right
thought and so on and so forth.
So in other words, the category ridge,
the property of being a ridge
here is being imposed by an
epistemic mind on an underlying world,
which is in fact much richer
than in fact those categories
can in fact do justice to.
Another example,
there's an artist by
the name of Adam Lowe,
a good friend of mine who--
And we've talked about
what the world's like.
And he painted this picture.
This is meant to be a realistic picture,
but in the following sense
that if our perception
renders the world's richness
intelligible by our packaging it up and
labeling it and categorizing
it and smoothing the boundaries
and so on and so forth.
He couldn't paint a picture
of what the world was like
and to make any point because
our perceptual apparatus
would be looking at the picture.
And it would just construct the picture
in categories and smooth
out the boundaries
and so on and so forth.
Then we'd just love to look at picture.
So, he's not an algebraist,
but to put this in algebraic terms,
if you assume that perception
computes F of a scene,
what he's painted here is a conception,
his conception of F to the
minus one of that scene.
In other words,
this differs from reality by
the amount by which we in fact
smooth out reality in order to fit it into
our conceptual scheme so that
when our perception sees this,
it's actually given to us
in our judgment as something
like the raw material
with respect to which we
see the world in general.
And what's interesting about
this is I can completely read
this picture, I don't know if you can.
And I apologize,
it's probably not the best on this,
on Zoom.
But, I'll just point out something.
There's a door over here
with some lumber inside
and a step ladder leaning over and stuff.
You can sort of tell that.
Down here there's a pail.
That's not too hard to see.
On the right hand, what's it called?
Anyway, the right hand
side of the doorway.
There's a mobile phone, a
1980s kind of mobile phone
anchored to the right hand post there.
(coughs) Excuse me.
There's a box,
yeah, in there inside the room
with lots of sticks of kindling sized wood
and so on and so forth.
And over here is a
person crossing over to--
And actually to pick up the phone
it turns out from other
aspects of this picture
and so on and so forth.
You don't necessarily read
these things as door and pale
and box and person and so on and so forth.
And telephone immediately.
But, what he is sort of
claiming this picture is
we actually do, do that
kind of classification
and categorization on inputs.
And one of the things
that's troubling about AI
is when AI first put television
cameras on systems back,
you know, 150 years ago when I was young.
People were astounded by
the messiness of the world
that the cameras that
were the camera outputs
because they thought that in
fact the camera was looking at
like nice scenes of, you know,
nice scenes of vases of flowers on tables
or something like this.
Still life.
And it was a mess.
It was a mess.
And people were astounded that, oh my god,
we deal with this mess.
So...
So, the point is this,
this orientation says that, look,
the fact that in what
philosophy actually calls
our natural attitude,
the fact that we take the
world to be conceptual.
To be consisting of objects and properties
and categories and stuff.
That's not how it actually
is in and of itself.
It's a human achievement.
The fact that it looks
like it is that way.
And in fact a lot of philosophy
has been distracted into
thinking that it just is that way,
aboriginal, is because that, in fact,
has been processed by the very cognition
that we're trying to understand.
So, okay, so suppose I tell
this to students and they say,
well, what else could it be?
Now, it's hard to answer that in language,
especially in intellectual
context like AI courses
and philosophy courses
and so on and so forth.
In intellectual context
such as science philosophy
and so on and so forth,
in which people assume
that language is conceptual
in the sense that we talked about before.
It would not be as hard
to convey in a sense,
in a classroom or a community or something
of people who were not themselves.
Scientists or philosophers
or AI people and stuff.
If it was a, you know,
class of poets or something like that,
it would be easier, I think,
to get them to realize that in fact,
the world doesn't come chopped
up in this corpuscular way
that Nunberg talked about it.
So, how can I convey to you
what the world might be like?
Well, I wanna make one suggestion,
I'm gonna make other suggestions
before the end of this talk.
And this first suggestion
is just by way of
prying open this possibility.
I'm not trying to put
too much weight on it.
But in a 1964 book called "Individuals",
Peter Braunstein introduced
the notion of a feature,
I mean not exactly introduced,
but I mean developed
the notion of a feature,
as something more basic
and less committing,
less ontologically committing,
than a property
as something that can be
exemplified in space and time.
Manifested in space and time
without actually needing an
object for its exemplification.
(Coughs) Excuse me.
So, suppose I say it's
raining or we say, it's foggy.
Everybody knows that there's
no 'it' that is foggy.
Or no, 'it', that's raining.
It's a kind of linguistic.
It's actually called "the
weather it" in linguistics.
It's an 'it' that doesn't refer.
But the idea of features is that,
look, the features are just manifested
in absolutely rich ways
throughout the world.
Cross-cutting and in vortices
and so on and so forth,
without actually requiring
object identities
underneath them.
One way to imagine this is to
imagine falling war boarding
in a storm at sea surrounded
by nothing but crashing waves
and stinging spray and undulating currents
and so on and so forth as
far as the eye can see.
And then subtract you,
so there are no objects there at all.
I think that in fact
the world of physics--
Now, Priya's a physicist.
So, I look forward to her comment on this.
I actually think that's kind
of what the world is like
according to physics.
You might not think that it's that way
because physics, in fact,
often talks in terms of objects.
You know, there's a mass of
three kilograms traveling at
this, four meters per second
off slides of a table,
a meter high, where does it land?
And so on and so forth.
The various objects in this situation,
a mass of three kilograms,
a table and so on.
But those objects are not
ontological commitments
of physics.
Those objects are epistemic
practices of doing physics,
the theoretical enterprise,
so that we can in fact
work out our equations.
But the equations don't
quantify over the objects.
They quantify over the
measures of the properties
or features that in fact are exemplified.
And even if you think about
the gravitational law,
G times M1 times M2, divided by R squared,
I think if I recall correctly.
One of the things you do in
your first year physics class,
at least I did 150 years ago,
was you prove that in
fact you can treat masses
as point masses at the location
of the center of gravity
for purposes of calculating
gravitational attraction.
But, that's not ontological commitment
of the physics underlying it.
The ontological commitments of physics
underlying it is that in
fact masses, the, you know,
it's a density field
spread out over a region.
And if you really wanted to
express the law of gravity
in a way that actually didn't
make this epistemic assumption
for the convenient physicists,
you would have to express
the law of gravity
as a double, triple integral
and so on and so forth.
Because there aren't objects in physics.
I think that's right.
And I actually don't think
there are many objects
in science either.
So, that will generate a lot of cortisol,
I suspect, in many audience members.
But I think that idea,
I mean it goes with field
theoretical interpretations
of physics more too.
That idea that maybe you could
make sense of physics as a
kind of characterization of features
placed continuously in the world.
The fact that that might be intelligible
suggests that features
might be an intelligible way
of taking the world to be,
which means that in fact
conceptual ontology isn't
necessarily the only way to
take the ontological structure
of the world.
And that's really why I want them here.
However, features are problematic too.
Because in fact, the whole
assumption of features,
like in field thetic interpretations
is that the feature is
the same feature that's
exemplified in lots of different
places and so on and so forth.
So, it's just a step
towards relinquishing the...
The grip of the conceptual
ontology as a presupposition
for how the world is structured.
I think a better way that we can go,
or a way that we can
go deeper a little bit
is to see how conceptual and
non-conceptual representation.
Okay, the two epistemic
practices we talked about
might fit into a amount of
physical or ontological picture
of this sort of a world
of surpassing stupifying
richness and operate as
kinds of abstraction over it.
So, four points.
First point is that this is not,
and this is another form of reductionism,
that this is not to go to
Priya's great question.
It is not a view that the
world is built up from atoms
or elementary pieces or
ultimate constituents
of our ontological life.
And that in fact, complex
or high level or something,
objects are in fact
assemblages of lower levels.
It's more like a Jamesian blooming,
buzzing confusion conception of the world,
but not in the sense which
James is often understood.
It's that the blooming buzzing confusion
is under if--
Undifferentiated K-pop.
Rather, what I'm trying
to get at is an idea that
the world is sort of
infinitely heterogeneous,
stupefyingly complex.
And that we navigate and wrestle it into
comprehensible form in order
to make our way in our,
you know, in our poultry
resource limited lives.
So, another point,
one merit of this view
that conceptual ontology
is an epistemic achievement
on top of a world
of surpassing richness,
is that it provides a way to account for
the most important insight, I think,
and commitment underlying science studies,
underlying feminist epistemology
and so on and so forth.
That concepts are normative.
And not just concepts, but objects.
They are the locus of value,
they're culturally relative,
all these kinds of stuff.
How does it make room for that?
Because in fact,
what it suggests is that
a conceptual abstraction
of the world,
so a conceptual judgment is true
when the thereby abstracted situation,
what you take the ridge to
be and so on and so forth.
Satisfies the norms,
the dynamic norms governing the lives
of the creatures who perform it.
So, if Priya is a geologist,
and I'm a mountain climber,
and I climb a peak
in the Kluane wilderness
in Yukon where there's
a Mount Ross that I think is 19,000 feet.
And I say, oh look, I've
climbed the highest peak in,
you know, or whatever,
just the last peak over
8,000 meters or something.
It probably isn't 7,000
meters, something like that.
It doesn't matter.
I'm a philosopher,
so I don't need the deal in pesky facts.
If I say I climbed all
of the 7,000 meter peaks,
and Priya says, no, look,
you haven't because you're on
this peak, but over there about
seven meters to the right,
it dips a little bit and then
there's another little rise.
And so that technically is a peak
and you haven't been there.
Now I could say, look, that's
not what I mean by peak.
That's not the category peak
that I'm using for my climbing.
And it might be a category
peak that she's using
for her geological survey
or something like this.
But the point is that, how to
understand my category of peak
is with respect to mountain climbing,
and the norms that
govern mountain climbing
and so on and so forth.
This is what the feminist
epistemologist I think are are on
about incorrectly so that--
- Brian.
- Yeah.
- Quick question.
- Yes.
- But, there needs to
be a consensus, right?
On the definition of peak,
even amongst just the mountain climbers.
- Well,
- Or do you need the
definition of a peak to be
some part of objective reality
that cannot be contested by anyone?
- Well, I--
Low there be lawyers.
I actually don't think that there are--
I mean there the structure of agreement
and consensuality and communion
and so on and so forth,
that's a huge topic in science studies
as to how that stuff gets worked out.
There was a famous case of
a racehorse which crossed,
and as to which horse won the race.
And there was one horse
and its nose looked like
it was further ahead than the one behind,
but the one behind was like
an inch behind or something.
The rider argued that it had
won the race because in fact
there was spittle coming
out of the nostril
of the horse that was behind.
And the spittle was
continuous with respect
to that horse and that the spittle
crossed the finish line before
the nose of the other one did.
And so that constituted
that horse winning.
And it went to court.
I mean, it went to court as
you could imagine such things.
I think the second horse won actually.
But, it doesn't matter
who won, it's that--
There has to be good enough
agreement for practices to work.
And I think it's just not true that
categories in general
get resolved, absolutely.
There's politics.
And you know,
sometimes there's been
really pernicious politics
behind these judgements.
You know, who's a person and stuff,
who gets to vote.
You know, right now, with respect to
whether in fact it's illegal to
put a pregnant woman in prison
because you're putting two
people in prison, you know, that's--
That category's absolutely
not well agreed and so on.
So, there'd be politics I think.
- Okay.
- But the point is this is a huge...
This is a huge issue in,
I mean this is something we could talk to
Joe Ress about tomorrow.
The sort of politics of the negotiation
of conceptual agreement
and so on and so forth,
in different fields.
A big topic, I think.
- Thank you.
- Here really is just that the...
The metaphysical picture here,
that in fact the concepts
and categories and stuff
are abstractions in terms of
which we try to fit reality.
Is that...
Okay.
Are they out there in the objective world?
Well...
Here's the thing.
It's generally accepted in philosophy that
semantics needs naturalizing.
We need an account of semantics
of how reference works
and how thought works
and so on and so forth.
What I'm saying here is that ontology,
in the sense of conceptual ontology,
what an object is that
needs naturalizing too.
Because the process of abstraction
that underwrite the
grouping and individuation
into individuals and so on and so forth,
which is essential to our
understanding of cognition,
are no less mysterious and no
more secured by a mechanistic
or causal scientific worldview.
No more autonomously integrable
with results in your temporary science
than any other of the
challenges and features
of intentionality.
So for example, if an amoeba splits,
is that two new amoeba, or
is one of them same one.
Or is it one that is dually
instantiated in the world?
If you have a redwood tree and
there's all kinds of fronds,
is that what they're called
growing up out of the roots?
And some of these things
can be 30 feet tall
and so on and so forth.
Are those lots of different redwood trees
or the same redwood tree?
You know, science remarkably
doesn't care about
such things, I think.
Because I don't think, as I said before,
I don't think science
is actually committed
to conceptual ontology.
And I think to assume as so
much of philosophy and logic
and XML and so on and so forth,
assume that the world of objects,
properties and so on
exists independently of us
and objectively and so on and so forth.
is essentially to suggest that the world
is autonomously conceptual.
And that's an especially
pernicious way of succumbing
what's called the myth of
the given, in philosophy.
But...
But, and this is an important but,
and it's really, really tough to convey.
On this picture, conceptual content, okay?
The epistemic nature of conceptuality.
So, the nature of that I
talked about in the conceptual
representation part of the talk,
not the conceptual
world, part of the talk.
And it's the conceptual
representation part that's relevant
to logic involves loss.
That's what abstraction means, throw away.
You throw away vast amounts of detail.
Why?
In order to support generalization
and long distance inference.
So, for example,
one thing I learned when
I moved to California is,
in New England, if you wander
around in the countryside
and you get lost.
If you wanna find a road,
you go down to the bottom of the valleys
cause that's where the roads are.
In California, when
you're wandering around
outside San Francisco in
the Santa Cruz mountains,
and you wanna find a road,
you go to the top of the ridge.
They're not at the bottom of the ridge.
Now that's a generalization and
that generalizes over all of
the differences between these
ridges and so on and so forth.
Generalizations of the sort
that fit into logical inference
require letting go of
massive amounts of detail.
But, what about the ridge
that in fact, we
identified in that picture.
Or the ridge that I climb up
in order to find a road
or something like that.
Think of the ridge is in
those waterfall plots.
Even if I register as an object
by abstracting away from the details,
the ridge itself is
not thereby abstracted.
And the reference of the phrase that ridge
is not necessarily abstracted either.
So if I say,
look, I'm gonna climb that ridge
and you saying, look,
you're never gonna make it.
You may be referring to the
richness of the ridge itself,
not to the richness of
it registered as a ridge.
Go back to that picture of whitewater
I had at the beginning.
If you argue that, I mean,
another part of philosophy
talks about issues
of vagueness,
that words like rapid or
eddie or something are vague,
because maybe there's no facts,
no absolute facts of the
matter as to how many rapids
are at ease or something
there are in that picture.
But again, the vagueness,
I think it's mistake to call it vagueness.
But even if it were okay
to call it vagueness,
there's nothing vague about the river.
If you're paddling down that
river and your life's at stake,
there's nothing--
You don't run into anything vague.
You run into extremely concrete detail.
What's vague, if anything is,
is our epistemic description
of it as a eddie or a rapid
or something like this.
And more importantly,
it's interesting that if
you want to actually act,
if you wanna put your finger just there
where the wind is strongest,
or crack the pattern of
animal motion against
a background of grasses,
or flip through of crack
in a wall or something.
Then the rich detail is
necessary for fine grain action.
In other words, the
super fluidity of detail,
because it's so detailed,
is not good for long distance
reasoning and planning
or inference, but it's
absolutely necessary for action.
So, suppose I wanna reach
for a cup here of coffee,
which I don't have, but unfortunately.
And I say, okay, I'm gonna pick
up this cup and I reach out.
Now, if you look at slow motion videos
of this kind of stuff,
it's kind of remarkable.
I may think that I'm
gonna pick up the cup,
if that's a conceptual thought.
And it may be that the conceptual thought
leads to my hand in that direction.
But as I get close to it,
there are sub-conceptual representations
that kind of take over and
adjust my fingers and my hand
and orient my hand and so on and so forth.
Through non-conceptual representation,
so as to be prepared to more
exactly know how they should
pick the cup up so that I don't dump it.
And the same thing for serving tennis
or meeting in the corner on
a motorcycle or something.
So, to try to wrap up here a little bit,
representing or otherwise
dealing with the local
ever so rich feature array,
or even more stupifying
detail in the world
is good for controlling action
and good for responding to fine detail,
but it's bad for long distance
imprints in generality.
This leads to a picture of what
I call metaphysical monism,
but ontological pluralism.
Because what happens is we people,
maybe other creatures too,
live in a continuous
creative tension between
the incredible richness of the world.
And the long distance utility
of language abstraction
and inference on the other.
When we engage with the world,
we wanna do the operative abstraction,
we want to kind of reconcile
or concretize our ideas
with respect to reality
to let more of the world's
ineffable details fill our representations
in order to be appropriately
responsive in action
to the world's fine grain detail.
But when we want to travel long distances,
by which I mean maybe
conceptual long distances,
we wanna figure out
where in fact we're gonna
button mine in Northern Canada.
We can go into where the neutrino
flux will be the highest,
when the sunspot arrives or whatever.
Then we have to, in fact,
to do science,
we have to let go of a lot of detail
and employees spare more efficient methods
purposely designed for inferential travel.
And if we're clever,
and we're damn clever,
I think there's nothing
more important about AI than
it teaches you humility.
We must in fact do both.
Basically, living in
this middle realm between
engaging with the detail,
letting go of the detail.
Allowing different
forms of representation,
conceptual or not, and so on and so forth,
to allow us both to think and to act.
And I sometimes think of
objects, properties, and relations.
In other words, the
conceptual material of ont--
The material of conceptual ontology.
I think of the objects,
properties and relations,
the things we started with,
as the long distance trucks
and interstate highway systems
of intentional normative life.
undeniably essential
to overall integration
of life's practices.
Crucial, given finite
resources for us to integrate
the vast open-ended terrain of experience
into a single, cohesive, objective world.
But the cost of packaging
them up for portability
and long-distance travel,
is that it insulates them
from the extraordinary
fine great richness of the
particular indigenous life,
the ineffable richness of
the very lives they sustain.
And what's magic about us
is that we live this dance
between them, among them,
so as to both live and be able to think.
Okay, so that's the end of part four.
And if I have two more minutes,
I'm just gonna say this epilogue,
which I think is kinda interesting.
This--
Think about any AI,
contemporary AI systems, right?
They end up doing inference,
which is not obviously conceptual.
And you know, you end up with vectors,
you know, 10,000 dimensional
vectors or something
with real numbers and so on and so forth.
And it just,
you have this incredible richness.
There's a huge amount of pressure
to make explicable, right?
To explain these things.
Which basically means,
look, render these judgments
into conceptual form.
And I think part of the
picture I'm arguing is,
look, that's--
You gotta be careful about that.
I know Priya, when I see her,
and I think if I ran into
her in the streets of Miami
where I didn't expect her.
I would say, "Oh my god, Priya.
You're, you're in Miami.
What brings you here?"
And then if somebody comes
up behind me and says,
"How do you know that's Priya?"
I haven't a bloody clue.
Because my recognition of Priya as Priya
is in fact not conceptually
available to me.
It's probably not actually
in conceptual form at all,
because I probably don't have concepts
that are actually adequate
to the detail that I use
to in fact, recognize
this particular person.
So, how do we explain?
Well I've got one more slide.
Here's a very short
sentence, just 23 words.
It's the first sentence of
Henry James' Portrait of a Lady,
which for some reason I
remembered all my life.
Under certain circumstances,
there are few hours in life
more agreeable than the hour
dedicated to the ceremony
known as afternoon tea.
Now, think about afternoon tea
about that, concept if you like.
What I think is interesting is,
you know, our current models of logic
would take afternoon tea
as referring to the concept
of afternoon tea,
which is a concept of exemplified by all
forms of afternoon tea.
But that's not a God-given insight
that that's necessarily
afternoon tea means or refers to.
And you can think of James
as actually very clever.
And you know, Steinbeck's another author
who's amazing at this.
Just with a few words, can
actually lead a concept
to in fact, have a specificity
that absolutely transcends
our ability to get at it
with a single word.
And from AI point of view,
you can see how this might work.
If you get all of the other
variables arranged in such a way
that they can sort of focus
in on what it is that this
concept is getting at in
this particular circumstance
that you're in fact abstracting
in certain sorts of ways.
I actually think it
might be an inspiration
as to how to explain things.
So, if you said to some medical system,
look, what do you think we should do?
Why are you prescribing this drug?
Anxiety drug or something.
And imagine the system saying, well look,
it's as if this guy was
told that they were about to
experience a huge shock,
as if waiting for a
diagnosis after surgery,
but they actually have only
the vaguest premonition
of what it's gonna be about.
Or she's gonna be in a--
She's in a state reminiscent
of the one that her sister
experienced after sailing
single-handedly across the roaring
forties on her solo
trip to Antarctic or so.
Go back to what Nunberg said
about how the chopping up of
narrative into corpuscular bits
at the beginning of the
age for information,
gave us this notion of
corpuscular recombinable
corpuscular data
that somehow we're trying to mine it for
the richness of the world.
That might be wrong.
It might be that we need to realize that
novels and poetry and
letters and that narrative
is actually a locus of the understanding
that fine tunes things in such a way
that you can get a better sense
of the richness of the world
that these things are about.
And what would be the
consequence of actually
taking that on board as an
epistemic ontological assumption
for the future of AI?
I don't know.
But, I appreciate your attention.
Thanks very much.
- Thank you so much, Brian
for this absolutely wonderful talk,
addressing so many
important deep issues in
what constitutes conceptual understanding
and therefore informs
inferences there from.
That was a really well--
- Well, right.
Sorry, could I interrupt
already? (chuckles)
Priya knows that I'm not easily shut up.
(Priya chuckles softly)
Our current models of
inference are conceptual.
- Right. Right.
- And I think that the
intriguing possibility
is that second wave AI,
although we don't understand how,
is showing this inference
may actually not need to be conceptual.
And we may not know how to explain it,
but it may show us that
inference can in fact
occupy other places in this realm.
So, I just think, I mean,
I don't think you probably
disagree with that,
I just think it's interesting.
- No, I don't disagree with that.
Right.
So, no, I know with you that
I have to be extra careful
with the language, right?
So, you always catch
me on that every time.
So I want to--
Why don't I start off
with one sort of question,
burning question that I have
and then open it up to the floor?
So, I invite everyone to
please start typing in
your questions in the chat.
So, I noted when you mentioned,
you know, generalizations, right?
So, generalizations require
discarding details, right?
And hence information, right?
And I wonder how this impacts
what we can infer from
generalized data, right?
Do we lose or do we capture?
So, do we manage to--
Do we efficiently capture
what is really needed
to robustly infer or?
- Well, first of all,
I think there's no doubt
that generalizations
are articulated with respect
to what I would call,
registration schemes,
which in fact ignore lots of details
in order to get at
higher level regularities
and so on and so forth.
When we put those things in,
in our system as it were,
we may have other details.
So if you think about,
I mean really some quite
politically problematic
systems that have determined,
you know, recidivism rates
as to who should actually be
allowed out of prison and who should not,
or chances of success
in college, you know?
And you know, all kinds of
other things about this person
such as their median income
and the nature of the
neighborhood they're in,
and the racial profile
of the neighborhood.
If we were doing inference
in a classical way,
which is, say, a conceptual way,
we might actually just
base that decision, let's say,
about whether they should
be admitted to Yale
on their grades or something like that.
But if you train an AI system,
it's going to use all of the
other detail that it has.
And that's probably not a
conceptually formulated filter.
And the worry is that to some extent,
well of course there are lots of worries.
One is that, the result will be heinous
in a whole variety of ways that
it'll reinscribe, you know,
it'll reinscribe biases
that are already there.
People struggle with fairness,
they put in protected categories
and so on and so forth.
But, you know, that's a,
that's a very tough thing to do.
I mean, it's not tough to--
I mean, people do it,
but ethically, it's kind
of complex to in fact,
protect certain categories
because that's a form of
prejudice also.
And I think that the
challenge of these systems,
I mean, one way to
understand the challenge
of these systems, if you
read these books like,
"Weapons of Mass Destruction",
and, you know, a book I prefer actually.
There the--
By Brian Christian, what's it called?
Anyway,--
- Yeah.
I've read that.
- "The Alignment Problem".
Yeah, "The Alignment Problem".
They document all kinds of problems.
And sure enough, these are problems.
But, what's going on with these problems?
Well, I think partly--
You know, and the fact that
you can't necessarily--
You might think, look, I'm
not gonna put the person's
racial background or something
is explicit variable,
and then these systems
can figure it out anyway.
We don't quite know how to deal with
the richness in this statistical data
with all of the parameters.
Right?
Doesn't GPT-3 have something like
1.5 billion parameters?
- Yeah.
Yes.
- You know, what the hell does that mean?
And--
- But GPT-3 is uncanny.
I went in at an exercise.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And because I've published
a lot that's out in the world,
I said, in the style of Priya.
- Right.
- Argue for X.
- Yeah.
- It was stunning.
I was stunned.
And it really could have been my words.
And--
- Well,
so I mean, it is stunning.
I think even the conversation
that was published with Lambda,
this bought at Google,
which the creator thought
was consciousness--
Conscious and got fired
and so on and so forth.
It's really stunning.
I mean, if my parents were still alive,
I would have them read it.
It's like, oh my God,
this can in fact happen.
Now...
One question is, you know,
what's going on with those systems?
Should we trust them?
And so on and so forth.
Do they know what the hell
they're talking about?
And stuff.
That's not this talk.
That's more what the promise book
that I wrote a couple years ago is about.
And I think the answer is no.
This is where I think Gebru's
notion of stochastic
parrots actually applies,
which is that you've
written in law enough.
I mean, the space of possibilities,
of the construction of human sentences is,
you know, is stupefyingly large.
The number that have been
said is of measure zero
compared to that,
you've charted a certain
sub-region of this thing.
It can have certain kinds of patterns,
and these systems can
recognize them and stuff.
But, I trust what you say.
I'm not gonna trust, at least I well,
better not trust a system
that is merely mimicking
your speech patterns.
You know, I wanna know
what you care about,
what you stand for.
What you would go and stand
in front of a bulldozer for.
You know, if a building were burning down,
what would you in fact do?
Even if you've never
statistically run into
the situation before.
So, those ethical situations, I think
are outside the can of these systems.
But imitating the style, you know,
it's damn impressive.
And I think it's doing it
because it's doing inference,
sort of non-conceptual
inference over these details.
Because computers can
handle a lot of data.
But we need to understand
that it's non-conceptual.
We need to understand
what's the world like,
such that it's in fact, getting this data.
What was the origin of data?
You know, if we've got something in there
about how many young people smoke.
And turns out that the data
come from American Airlines,
and you're only a young person if you're--
You're an adult if you're over two
because you need your own seat.
You know, all these questions
about the categories,
the norms of the categories.
That's the kind of question that I think,
in a way, I'm trying to sort of suggest
the intellectual arsenal of
forms of understanding we need
in order to understand what it is
that these systems are doing.
Not just to be impressed by them,
because otherwise we're gonna be
too bloody impressed by them.
- Yeah, I totally agree.
Thank you very much.
So, we have a couple of questions.
The first one is from Peter Morgan.
And he says, "Perhaps
a process or algorithm
that renders non-conceptual life/ living
into conceptual form.
But I think you say
one has to be careful about that process.
I suppose we can have
a non-conceptual sense
of how we render the algorithms
that perform the render,
but can we render that algorithm itself?
Is this a reasonable question,
given that this leads to a recursion?"
- Well...
Okay, another glass of something to drink.
I would need to understand
what you mean by
an algorithm that renders conc--
Actually, forget the
algorithm for the moment.
I'd like to know what
you mean by rendering
non-conceptual life and
living into conceptual form.
Because that would suggest
assessing a life, I guess.
A life process or something of
probably ineffable richness.
And in fact, abstracting it in such a way
that it's fitting into a set of concepts.
And I would wanna know
whose concepts those are.
Are they yours?
Are they the systems itself?
Even if they're the systems itself,
that doesn't prove that
that exhausts the life,
because I think most of
our life, we, in fact,
most of our thinking is in fact
not conceptual in form, I think.
You know, if you're driving down the--
If we're driving in a car down the highway
and I am driving and I say,
"Actually, sorry,
I've just been struck completely blind,
but I'll keep driving.
You just tell me what to do."
You ought to be scared outta your mind
because you can't say, look,
turn a little bit to the right
or turn 27 degrees to the left.
That's not gonna actually
lead me to do the right thing.
And at what speed and so on and so forth.
I think most of our physical
navigation is in fact
navigated in terms of sub
conceptual representations.
So, I don't think you can,
I don't think you can render
non-conceptual living systems
into conceptual form,
unless you're in an
artificial life situation
or something like that.
And I think that's one of the
things that makes those things
inexorably indelibly artificial.
And sexual representation is lossy, right?
It does and it has to,
and it's important because it does
lose enormous amounts of a detail
in order to get at higher
level regularities.
The life can't, in fact,
let go of these of
details or it would die.
So, yeah.
I just don't actually understand, I guess,
what rendering a non-conceptual life
into conceptual form would mean
other than describing in conceptual terms.
And I think it's a theorem
that if you prescribe a
non-conceptual life in conceptual terms,
you're gonna be missing a lot of detail.
Sorry, I don't mean to be obstructionist.
But I would need to know
what's going on better
in order to know if we can answer it.
- Yeah.
So, we can move on to the
next question by June Lou.
So, the implication of
this view for inference
is the question,
does it mean that inference
cannot be adequately
licensed conceptually, that is,
if P given even P and P greater than Q,
entering Q is not automatic or autonomous,
but rather requires
non-conceptual orientation
to what P and Q are actually about.
Likewise, the example of
recognizing Priya in Miami,
which AI practitioners
today do call inference,
seems to suggest that the
warrant of such inference
is non-conceptual.
With the non-conceptual
aspects, hopefully.
- Well, I think...
I think that,
yes, so take the P and P and Q.
Or implies Q.
If we go syntactic.
There are reasonable conditions in this.
Reasonable conditions underlying
even conceptual inference
of that sort, which I think
even a logician would recognize.
Which in fact, limit
the application of that.
So, for example,
you know, Sorites paradoxes
and so on and so forth,
the P is standing next to Q,
then P is near q and Q
is standing next to R,
then Q is near R.
But if you do that for 10,000 people,
then in fact, P is not near
the person who's 10,000 away
and so on and so forth.
So, how do you know how far these sort of
partially transitive things go?
You know, the applicability of, you know,
somebody who's young,
one year younger than them
is also young, and I mean,
one year older than them is also young and
all these kinds of things.
It's kind of trivial for
introductory logic students
to come up with examples
which violate the norms of
conceptual inference.
And I think what the logic
teachers typically say is, look,
you have to operate within
a regimen of reasonableness.
The problem is that when we
automate this stuff in systems
and have, you know,
databases being swallowed
up by these systems
and so on and so forth,
we actually don't know
what the reasonable
conditions are and so on.
You know, this is an ancient example,
but when I was in MIT,
there was this, you know,
as I said, 150 years ago.
There was this system of medical diagnosis
and it was asked how to cure
a kidney infection and it said,
take the kidney out and boil it.
Now, that system lacks something.
And, so people tried to
axiomatize common sense,
and they've tried to
axiomatize humanize causality
and they've tried to axiomatize
all these sorts of things.
Axiomatization in the classical mold
is simply a conceptual
rendering of what's going on.
And I think the reason that
second wave AI has trounced
not necessarily forever, I mean,
there's a whole discussion here,
but the reason that I think it's
kind of tranced classical
AI is that in fact,
purely conceptual
inference has proved to be
inexorably brittle
because of the limitations
of the conceptual categories.
And the improved behavior of
these statistical algorithms,
I say, I think is because they
are not entirely conceptual.
That doesn't mean they're
the best thing in the world,
I don't think, for example,
this idea of having a
system explain itself
by constructing literatures,
which would constrain the
categories to mean what it is that
they mean in these particular things.
And so on and so forth.
This is miles beyond where we are now.
But yes, I think there are limits to,
there are limits to...
To conceptuality.
And I think it's important for AI to--
like you're coming about
recognizing Priya in Miami
as considered inference.
Maybe somebody in AI would call
that statistical inference.
- Yeah.
- What can we trust
statistical inference for?
That's a pretty core screened label
of what's going on, I think.
And I think the same issues
about statistical inference,
I mean, the fact that it's
based on this idea of data
where the data are
these corpuscular things
where the assumption is that the
instantiation of the properties
across lots of different
objects and lots of
different circumstances,
it's the same property
and so on and so forth.
I think there're,
you know, it's an advance over GOFI.
But I think lots of these
issues of homogeneity,
not knowing the norms that
underlie the use of the
categories and so on and so forth.
They're gonna, they're gonna defeat,
I mean, uncannily good as they look,
I think they're gonna defeat.
They're gonna defeat even this,
even second wave inference.
I think it, you know, it will be looked at
as narrow as first wave AI
inference is looked at now.
- Thank you.
We now have a question
from Sylvia who asked,
"Regarding the precision
of athletic decisions
involved in navigating whitewater rapids.
I think you were saying that
because we cannot conceptualize
the pools than rocks and
eddies around a bend,
notice that we nevertheless
steer and survive
without one causal inference.
Non-conceptual inference
takes the limitations of the
programmers coding out of the equation.
I like that, but I'm not a mathematician.
How would AI plant a garden?"
Oh, I love that question.
- Well, first of all...
Yeah, how would AI?
I mean, I don't think the
word AI has a stable enough
reference to enable me to
answer the last question.
Although my initial gut level
response was sitting down.
(Priya chuckles softly)
But the first thing about, you know,
the skill of going through this whitewater
with that one causal inference,
I think this goes back to Priya's point.
It isn't one causal inference
in the sense that inference
was classically thought about
in classical logical terms
and AI terms.
It probably is an inference
in the sense that June--
Genoa was just mentioning
that contemporary statistical
AI would actually take it
to be causal inference,
quite possibly continuous, you know,
dynamic interaction with an environment
in ways that honored causal consequences
and so on and so forth.
I kind of don't doubt
that you could build an AI
even kind of at the moment
that could manage a canoe
down some of these rivers.
I mean, I'm no expert,
I'm not a programmer.
So, I think we have to know better
what causal inference means.
I mean, Priya was laughing at me, I hope,
with respect to my needing
words well defined,
especially since I don't
believe in definitions.
But the issue of what the word mean,
it, you know, matters with
respect to this stuff.
Because in fact, by that
one causal inference,
we need to know what inference is such
that it doesn't involve it.
And we need to know what
inference might mean in the
statistical sense and so on and so forth.
In order to know what form of
attunement to the causality
structure of the world,
the systems are actually capable of.
Non-conceptual interest
takes the limitations
the program is coding outta the equation.
You know, that's very tricky.
I just taught this course on ethics of AI,
and this issue came up as
to whether the programmers
are in fact, culpable at all
for the results they come up with.
And some of the people
who actually work with
contemporary AI systems say,
look, the programmers do nothing.
They just programing causal, you know,
gradient descent among
huge regions of, you know,
spaces of continuous variable.
And in fact, programming causal
descent among them is not,
doesn't take genius even if
it pays you a lot of money.
But there are issues about
what data you're gathering
and so on and so forth,
which are pretty tricky.
I mean, if you have,
you know, a sex...
You know, an entry for sex or something
in a database and stuff,
you know, are you gonna
have sex and gender?
Or sex and--
Is it gonna be separate?
And sex, is it gonna be male or female?
Or is it gonna be XX, or XY,
or XYY, or XXY, or XO?
What about people who are
XY but don't have androgen
receptors and so they grow
up phenotypically female
and they don't actually
realize that they're XY
until they possibly get tests
for infertility later on
and so on and so forth.
Then it can be quite
shocking for them to discover
that they've been XY their whole life
and so on and so forth.
These categories are not innocent.
And you know,
and race of course is an
absolutely non-innocent category.
When I was a kid,
I asked my parents why--
I was like six or something,
why if a black person and
a white person had a kid,
the kid wasn't splotchy like a Jersey cow
or something like this.
And you know, I got laughed at.
But, I think the answer was because
race is not a biological
category, you know, and that's...
The can categories aren't innocent.
That's what feminist epistemologists,
and feminist scientists
and so on and so forth,
they've been arguing for so long.
These categories are inflected.
And partly what I'm trying
to do is to, I mean,
I dunno if this comes across,
I wanna do justice to that recognition
from the science studies
and feminist methodologist
and so on and so forth.
Even though I'm resolutely realist,
because I actually think this
stupifying surpassing detail
of the world is actually the same.
And if I and someone else
register it in different ways,
it's the same detail that were in fact
abstracting in various ways
that !suit our particular
cultural assumptions and norms
and so on and so forth. So.
- And Brian is this,
is this not much more salient
when we are thinking of like
standard, you know,
bottom of the barrel machine
learning tasks, for example,
where we provide a training set.
So, the choice of training set,
not only what data we collect,
but what we choose as the training.
- Well, right.
And how the,
how the training set was
gathered and on and on and on.
Yeah.
This is, um...
Yes, absolutely.
- Okay, so, Peter has another
quick comment and a question.
You mentioned that there is
a lossiness in how we think
about life.
Thought is a compression is his question.
- Well, yes, I think it's
a compression in a way.
I mean, it's tricky cause
the word compression
comes from information theory.
And the idea is that there's
information there and you know,
and the measures of information,
in fact buy into these
conceptual assumptions
and so on and so forth.
And so in lots of ways.
So, there's problems with circularity
in the foundation of the question.
I do think that thought
is lossy to some extent,
but I think that...
Remember I said we live
in this middle distance
between the detail and the
abstractions and stuff,
and we navigate them and we
take ethical responsibility,
moral responsibility for the abstractions.
We have to, I mean, we should anyway,
and navigating them
and so on and so forth,
and understanding how they would
go into practice and stuff.
And so if I say to a surgeon,
look, you've got to...
Oh and here's a real
example from the beginning
of Xerox Park when we first
made Windows and mice.
And the question was,
how fast the mouse should
track the, you know,
the cursor should track the mouse.
And somebody wrote up
a paper saying it was,
I don't know, whatever, 3.5 inches were
on the screen compared to an inch on the
pad or something like that.
And it turns out that's not what matters.
What matters is you wanna be
able to cross the whole screen
with a single rotation of the wrist.
The...
Well, I guess the point is it,
it it sort of the same one
that there's assumptions in the categories
in terms of which we construct
these non-conceptual representations
and so on and so forth
that we as programmers
kind of need to take
responsibility for.
And if things are, as Priya says,
and in fact a lot of the
problems are in how the data's
collected and what the data
assumes and so on and so forth.
The, you know, and students I had
in class this week,
this semester didn't think
the systems were capable
of taking ethical responsibility at all.
They didn't even occur to them
because they don't have this
model of AI that we had four years ago.
So, it's a mess.
It's a mess.
I mean, I would say yes,
thinking is loses a lot.
But good thinkers know how to
take responsibility for that,
which the thoughts lose.
- That's a great answer.
Thank you.
So, Gary has the next question.
"What is the implication of scale?
For example, a concept
of a person is fuzzy,
but what about the concept of a photon
or a gravitational field?
A star is a fuzzy concept,
but the feels created
by the star is precise."
- Well, okay, so here's a problem,
possibly with me.
I have never understood what people say
when they say concepts are fuzzy.
I may just lack the right gene.
But, I've had arguments with this with,
I remember John Holland and John McDowell
and a bunch of other people
at Chicago at the time.
Is it that, for example,
a person being fuzzy,
does it mean that there are
edge cases which we don't
know how to judge?
Does it mean their individual
edge cases are hard to judge,
but that we don't actually...
I mean one of these are,
we don't know how to define
it even though in a particular
case we would know how to use it.
Maybe we don't have to,
don't know how to apply
it to detail like bread.
You know, let's say we have, let's say,
let's have the opposite
of bread for supper
and somebody can say,
how can we have the
opposite of bread, right?
So, what's bread?
Is it hot cross buns?
Is it bagels?
Is it latkes?
Is it, you know, naan or chapatis?
Or I mean, God knows what.
But, is that fuzzy?
Like, I'm not sure it's fuzzy,
it's just not clearly applicable.
And it's grab on reality is maybe,
you know, looser.
Stars of fuzzy concept,
I guess you mean by that
maybe what kinds of fusion
you need in a system.
You know, there could be
levels of fusion which don't raise it to
actually being a star
in this kind of stuff.
Maybe there are conjoined star systems
which are so close that
it's not actually clear
if it's one star or two.
That would be a better case.
The fields created by the star is precise.
That's an interesting point because
one of the things that I think is true
about computer science
and to some extent by physics too,
is that we are used to
dealing with systems at
an enormously wide variety of scales.
You know, I mean I think computer science,
it regularly crosses like 15
orders of magnitude of scale
from picosecond junction transit times
to running times of Ethereum,
mining systems and so on and so forth.
And some of the categories
that apply at some levels
don't apply at others.
So for example, it might
be that the features
or the properties,
I think they might be
features that in fact
have precise boundaries
at very low levels.
When you put them together
in this complexity,
you end up at high levels
without there being completely
precise, you know.
So, taken being an...
An implementation of PDF reading,
that's surely fuzzy in some
sense in the PDF standard
is nobody actually
implements it completely.
And you're gonna have
things maybe for Microsoft,
which in fact do a reasonable job,
but in fact violate lots of cases.
And maybe they accept cases
which are not part of the PDF
but then practice goes
with what Microsoft does
rather than specification.
And then it becomes true
that if you write it to the specification,
it may not be accepted
as a PDF by Microsoft.
You know?
Or by Adobe Acrobat or whatever it is.
What happens to precision as you cross
scale boundaries is,
well, I think that ought to
be taught in high school.
I think these issues of scale,
how to think with scale
are hugely important.
And I mean the implication of scale is
we should think hard about it,
and think about what properties
cross scale boundaries
and which ones don't.
Maybe that's my answer.
Leave the fuzziness aside.
- Right.
So, I think at this time,
we probably have time for
just one more question
before we wrap up and if Brian is willing,
people can stay on a little bit after
officially to continue the Q&A.
So, we have this question
from Neils who says,
"Your examples seem to be
only on our perception and or
conception of the physical world.
Would your analysis also be
applicable to the social world
in concepts like democracy
or justice and social roles,
like being a judge?
A person either is or is not a judge,
which to me seems a bit
different from the ridge example.
Do you agree and if you do,
what are the consequences
for the generality
of your arguments?
Oof.
Big question.
- Well...
Yeah, fortunately I know Neils.
(Priya chuckles)
I would say they do apply.
I think the ca--
I mean this goes back to
Priya's question early on
about, look, we have to
have a social agreement
or even determination
of hack with respect to
category boundaries.
I think category boundaries is--
If you'll forgive me in analogy,
I kind of think of categories as,
as in the classical model
as being viewed at like
square waves in the following sense.
They are thought to have sharp boundaries
like the edges of the square.
So something either is or is not a judge,
as you say.
And then they're thought to
have flat tops in the sense that
the being a judgenness of
a given judge is the same
being a judgeness as someone else.
And I'm not sure that's right.
And I think that's one of the
sort of assumptions that is so deep
that I find it very difficult to actually
talk to students about
what it would be for it
not to be the case.
But whether a person is or is not a judge,
I would doubt that that's so clear.
I mean, suppose...
Oh, I don't know,
suppose I'm a devout
Catholic and I wanna actually
be married and I've been
hit by a car in an accident
and I've only got a few
hours to live and stuff.
And I just want a judge
to officiate our marriage
so that I can be at peace,
and feel like I won't go to
hell or something like this.
I'm sorry if I'm stepping all
over 86,000 toes doing this
example, but.
And somebody says, well
look, I was a judge.
I actually--
My license expired last week.
And I say, look, that's all right.
I don't care care about that.
Right?
My partner and I actually
don't even agree on
whether we're married
because we had a ceremony
with her 95 year old father
at the dining room table the
way that was classically done
in ancient times and we exchanged rings
and we had promises
and so on and so forth.
And it was wonderful cause at
the end of it he stood up and
raised a glass and said,
I'm so glad Brian, you've done this
cause I've always wondered
about your intentions.
And, (scoffs) you know,
only somebody at 95 could say
that with a smile, I think,
and mean it earnestly
and so on and so forth.
And to some extent that strikes me as
the authentic marriage.
It just wasn't the one
recognized by the state.
Except in Canada, it is
recognized by the state
and so on and so forth.
So, you know,
whether someone's a judge or not,
I mean, if you wanna reduce things to
the adequacy of formal documents,
then you get to what
Nunberg was talking about
with the rise of print and the sort of
corpuscularization of data.
And, you know, that--
The digital identity criteria
of print has in fact--
First of all recorded social facts,
but then actually become used
as in fact it determinates of
the boundaries of these categories.
And I'm...
So, I actually,
with with enormous respect
and with an amount of respect
that is not itself formally measurable,
I would differ with whether in fact
judges are or not judges.
- Okay.
So, I'm really tempted to
have one final question
included Brian, and
that's from Steven Hothma.
- Okay.
- "Great talk.
Near the end, you made the
point that these are not
quite your words," as he says,
"representing which detail
is good for action, but bad
long distance inference.
But as your examples show,
inference requires making the normatively
right abstractions that retain the details
that matter to the context.
This is non-trivial.
And I assume you would say
that the skill of making
context appropriate abstractions
is a form of a non-conceptual skill.
But if so,
does it mean that we'll never
be able to explain the success
of a generalized AI if we somehow manage
to achieve such a thing?"
- Well, great question.
Thank you, Steve.
I think that yes,
managing the loss in a way
that doesn't do violence
to what matters about the situation
is absolutely part of wisdom
and a part of being an adult, basically.
I have an enormous respect for that.
And I a hundred percent
agree that it's non-trivial.
And I think one of the things
that scares the wits outta me
is that we will not only
model our AI systems
on essentially trivial models
of judgment and inference.
But, then we will raise our
children to think that in fact,
doing judgment the way the
systems do is constitutes
being an adult and
we're gonna actually all
go down the drain
because of our conception of humanity
has been torqued by our
attempt ability systems.
And we're gonna lose exactly
these non-trivial things.
So yes, a hundred percent
see you and raise you one
on the non-triviality.
Whether it's a form of
non-conceptual skill,
I actually think it probably is.
However, your last sentence I have to--
I had people worked in
my group at Xerox Park,
40 years ago or whatever,
were gonna get me vanity license plates
when they first came out.
And the vanity license plate
they were gonna get me was,
"YES...BETBUT"
Which I'm afraid is actually
sort of appropriate.
Does this mean we'll
never be able to explain
the assess of a general AI?
First of all,
I don't think we're gonna get a general AI
if it in fact, buys into the current idea
of explanation being entirely conceptual.
If being conceptual is taken
to be this particular model
of conceptual that I've talked about here.
The thing I was trying to
say in my epilogue comment
about explainability is--
And actually, I mean throughout the talk,
I didn't make a big deal of it,
but anyone who is alert
to it, will have noticed.
I don't think the use of words
is intrinsically conceptual
in the sense that I've
characterized conceptuality.
I think poets and novelists,
and not only that,
but I think great intellectualism,
so on and so forth,
use words in ways that outscript
the constrictions on
conceptuality that I've,
that I think have been kind of
lionized and brought into formality.
I don't think we're gonna be
able to explain non-conceptual
judgments made by even--
Even the sorts of systems,
like how it is that a system
decides that you've got lung
cancer or doesn't, or was that
melanoma or not and so on.
I don't think we're gonna be
able to explain those things.
If we hang on to the traditional notion
of conceptual explanation.
That doesn't mean we can't
explain 'em using words.
I think this idea of
a system that can say,
well look, it's kind of like this,
remember this thing happened to you?
Remember the feeling you had then?
You know, it's this person
is kind of that state too,
but they're also whatever
and blah, blah, blah.
I mean, think of what a
really competent doctor can do
with respect to explanation.
It's often narrative in form.
And I think there's something
really weighty and worth pondering about
the substance of narrative
with respect to explaining
in ways that outscript
the model of conceptuality
I'm talking about here.
And the question is, how
will those be implied,
not only in explaining
the success of a general AI,
but actually in getting
us to a general AI?
So, see you and raise you one.
That's my answer.
- Great.
Anyway, I think at this point
we have kept you way too long, Brian.
So, I want to thank you once
again for a wonderful talk.
We look forward to the
discussion tomorrow with
Professor Rouse at the same
time, 3:00 PM as today.
And before we close, I want
to give thanks to Ty Kamp.
Without Dr. Kamp's help,
this entire series could not
have been managed at all.
So, thank you so much, Ty,
for everything that you do
and in particular for making
this series such a resounding success.
Thank you.
And to Guy,
- Hear, hear.
- Yeah.
And to Guy, without whose
AV help and expertise,
we would not be able to bring
this wonderful set of talks
to the general public.
Well for posterity,
whatever posterity means
with his help and skills,
we've been able to put
all of these lectures
on both our website and
the YouTube channel,
dedicated YouTube channel.
So, I invite you all to go take a look.
And with this, I want to say
thanks once again to Brian
and to everyone for attending
and helping make this wonderful
series such a success.
We are hoping to have a
conference in person next year
in the fall, so watch out for details.
Thanks very much.
Yeah.